The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
That's amazing man.
Now when you go and you do these,
uh,
these Mexico trips,
do you,
do you have someone who guides you and keeps you safe?
Like how do you.
Because I taught,
we had Anthony Bordain on and he said one of the things you've got to get a
local guy when you go to these crazy spots,
you get a local guy who's,
you know,
a handler and that guy takes care of everything in your town.
You pay him.
You guys do that?
Yeah.
You definitely have to have local guys.
I don't believe in security or definitely not like,
you know,
for sure not like western body.
Ours are like pilgrims or any of those big,
obvious,
visible big guy talking to him to their arrest and shit.
That's just stupid because they're just gonna attract attention.
Who the fuck is going on here?
Let's get them you.
Uh,
but definitely you need local fixers in Mexico.
We have 34 offices around the world.
So we,
we have our own guys,
local guys,
pretty much everywhere.
And then you have like local fixers who,
you know,
know the terrain,
know the language,
know what's going on and how to get you out of shit.
And you guys started this,
you were doing a magazine called voice and then you took it over and took the o
out and just called it advice.
Yeah,
it was,
it was called Voice of Montreal and it was a,
it was sort of a welfare project in Canada,
uh,
run by Haitians and they were doing a black history month thing and then they
figured they could get more money out of the government by doing an English
language cultural publication.
And so we were all working there.
I wanted to be a writer.
So I was like,
oh,
finally got a job
and be welcomed back.
Was trying to separate from the rest of Canada.
So like English language publications became illegal.
So no audience.
And uh,
so anyway,
eventually they couldn't pay us our wages and stuff.
So we said,
okay,
well we own it now.
So we dropped the O and just call it advice.
And like,
there was like,
what a great name.
How'd you,
how'd you think it?
And we're like,
we just dropped the o,
you know,
and it's a perfect story.
Yeah.
And then we moved to the states and then we,
then we started expanding and now we're in 34 countries.
And where are you guys based out of?
You're based out of New York,
New York and London are two or two hubs and our biggest office next year is
going to be in China.
And how long have you been doing this?
Sixteen years.
Holy Shit.
No Man.
God Damn.
Now it's music.
It's you even have a clothing line and everything now.
It's a record label and films and TV and a mag and online and all our different
verticals and events.
And
that's awesome.
Was this a plan from the very beginning to branch off in all these different
directions and it just sort of naturally happened?
Yeah,
no,
there was,
we never had a business plan.
We never knew anything.
We never thought about it really.
What happened was uh,
you know,
we wanted the outlawed English basically in Quebec.
So we,
we went national in Canada where the biggest magazine in Canada,
but that was like being the biggest magazine in Reykjavik or something where the
number one podcast in Canada,
Canada.
I love Canada.
I love Canada
to try.
I'm going to move if shit gets bad.
Well I came real close in 2004.
I was looking at space in Vancouver.
Really?
Yeah,
I was thinking about it.
I wouldn't,
you gotta go to the cause it's going to get real bad.
You got to get to like one the north of where I grew up in Ottawa.
There's like a million lakes.
You can just buy a lake for like 100 bucks.
You got to buy a lake and you know,
build a cabin on the lake because when she gets bad you go to get it
far away from the cities.
When it gets that bad though,
you might want to just die.
You want to live like in Liberia,
you know,
I don't want to.
I want to live on.
I'd rather take a bullet know.
I'd rather take a bullet and live like that.
Us a stump odm.
Flintstone.
Yeah.
I don't think he can pry.
I think that's a roamer.
Um,
so you,
so you guys started now,
how did you get started from going from a magazine to these incredible in depth
on scene investigative pieces that you're doing?
What was the first one?
Heavy metal in Baghdad.
So,
um,
we for about a decade,
we were kind of a style Mac,
so we were really just interested in cocaine and supermodels
and so like these jeans are weird.
And uh,
we had,
it was because it was fun.
It was a lot of fun and we were kids and,
and uh,
and then when we started expanding around the world,
we're like,
shit is fucked up.
Like,
holy fuck.
I mean,
have you seen this?
You know,
and,
and we'd write about it and people like,
I've never heard about that,
what the fuck's going on?
And we're like,
yeah,
it's crazy.
So that happened as well as the sort of failure of mainstream media during,
um,
you know,
the Iraq war,
um,
with everyone saying like,
weapons of mass destruction just lying and they knew that there was no weapons
of mass destruction and all this shit.
And so,
um,
we did a thing where we went to,
we snuck into Iraq,
um,
and we went to hang out with the only heavy metal band in Baghdad across the
counter and it was supposed to be like a seven minute piece.
It was the first piece we launched the VBS with and um,
you know,
eventually we shot them over three years and we turned into a feature film that
one critic stories in Toronto at won best documentary in Berlin film festival.
Like it got picked up by the BBC,
by Ken Blues.
Yeah.
A friend Eddie raves about it.
Eddie Bravo raves about that.
And so everyone's like,
you know,
oh,
that's like news,
you know,
we're like,
we're following a band.
But you saw the whole thing unfold,
like how everything was fucked up shit.
And people could relate to it because like,
oh,
I'm in a band and then there are bad,
gets their,
a practice space,
gets bombed by a Scud missile and you know,
they,
they're going to be killed because they were like iron maiden tee shirts or like
they had bang,
which is seen as Jewish.
So they cut your head off and shit.
And so that was the first thing and it was so successful that.
And we love doing it that we started saying,
well why don't we,
the whole.
Everyone's like,
what's your been your demo and what's Your Business Plan?
And all this shit.
We're just like,
we have none.
All we do is stories that we like.
So if,
if,
if there's a story like general butt naked in the Tupac army,
that's a fucking jaw dropper,
we're going to go shoot that,
you know?
And so we started shooting it and people were like,
I've never heard anything like this.
What the fuck?
And so more and more and more people started watching and,
and,
and we started doing it more and more.
You're a fucking human being.